hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
fast track your biologics and ngs
workflows
with automated uv vis quant on lunatic
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
labrutz and brought to you by unchained
labs
to learn more visit unchainedlabs.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
nellis dennis
product manager lunatic and stunner at
unchained labs
felicia disarro joseph scientific
investigator
biofarm discovery gsk and
matt humes senior lab manager lab
automation
beam therapeutics nellis you may now
begin your presentation
hi thanks everyone for joining us in
this very exciting presentation
together with our two external speakers
we'll show how you can fast track your
biologics and ngs workflows
with automated your visquam on lunatic
i want to start with the most famous and
most successful example
of automation ever laundry when doing
hours of work with way too much soapy
water
everyone was ready for a better way for
sure when the piles of clothes just keep
getting bigger and bigger
for quantifying nucleic acids or protein
i'm sure everyone remembers the
spectrophotometers
where you could only load one centimeter
cuvettes that required at least 100
microliter sample
and read one at a time but like with the
laundry
uv spectrophotometry has evolved to
handle a big pile of samples
all automated and using less volume and
time
our lunatic is a full spectrum uv
spectrometer
which requires only 2 microliter per
sample and no dilution steps
nor standard curves liberty can measure
up to 96 samples at a time
in just 10 minutes using our plates with
two micro cuvettes
which allow reading higher concentration
samples
if you have samples with a low
concentration
we have a second plate with one micro
cuvette and the 96 samples will be read
in just
five minutes our plates have a standard
svs footprint so they're compatible with
liquid handling robots
now how does our lube lunatic do this
well lunatic is the only system out
there that can measure nucleic acids and
protein at high throughput and high
concentration
the microfluidic circuit with two fixed
path lengths
as you can see highlighted here covers a
wide dynamic range of 0.03
to 275 rd the unique microfluidic
circuits molded into lunatic plates
ensure that is no cross-contamination or
evaporation
fixed cuvettes make for accurate and
fast concentrations
since we can always be sure of the path
length used in bears loss calculations
it also allows us to correct for stray
light and other background
fixed path lengths mean you know exactly
what you're measuring
now let's take a more in-depth look at
how it works
samples are deposited into the input
well and drawn into the storage
channel by capillary action a sample can
be left in the storage channel for up to
2 hours without detectable evaporation
after the plate is loaded into the
instrument the empty micro cuvettes are
red first
and that will remove any absorbance
contribution from the plastic
and then a pump applies a small vacuum
which moves the sample into the micro
cuvettes
for reading now high lunatic plates have
two micro cuvettes in each circuit
with a 0.1 and a 0.7 millimeter pad
length
the two different size micro cuvettes
make the wide dynamic range
possible
luntic has an accuracy within two
percent at a precision within one
percent cv
this can be verified with the
fundamentals or third-party certified
standards
five trip defense standards at different
concentrations to check
accuracy precision and linearity
now here's a look at linearity accuracy
and precision
this shows an igg dilution series of 8
replicas from 2 micrograms per
microliter to 200 micrograms per
microliter
the close agreement between the target
concentration and the average
measured concentration shows off lunatic
spot on accuracy within two percent of
the expected value
with an r squared value of 0.9999
the low cv values across the dilution
range help
show off its precision
and the data shown here demonstrates how
lunatic generates the same
amazing results for genomic samples the
highest concentration of dna in this
dilution series
was 12.8 micrograms per microliter
the r squared value for the series
showcases the high linearity across the
huge dynamic range of lunatic
so just run your samples at
concentration you're
already working with don't add in extra
dilution steps
you don't need
here you can see a plot with three
concentrations of dna
either intra-instrument ran in a
duplicate on the same system
or inter-instrument ran in a duplicate
on eight different lunatic systems
for a total of 64 samples per
concentration
on one instrument we've already
discussed the amazing results earlier in
this presentation
now here we can see that with eight
completely different
systems there's also nothing to worry
about having systems in different labs
in the same building or even at
different sites globally
will always provide the same high
quality results
and the features don't stop there we
have iqoq procedures available and for
labs doing manufacturing quality
assurance and quality control
lunatic now has a performance
verification for new instruments
these tests with certified curvettes
meet the united states pharmacopoeia and
the european pharmacopoeia
guidelines for uv spectrometers the
tests
and all necessary calculations are
completely handled
automatically by the software
and now i'm very glad to introduce you
to our first external speaker
matt humes is the senior manager lab
automation at beam therapeutics
based in cambridge massachusetts
he gained his bachelors in biochemistry
at estonia brook university of new york
and is working on his masters in
bioengineering at harvard
previously matt built his expertise as
supervisor automation and regenerative
pharmaceuticals
where he installed more than 30 liquid
handlers 5 fully integrated systems and
3 biobanks
within his current role he oversees beam
therapeutics lab automation
and robotic efforts without further ado
i'll
gladly hand it over to matt now
thank you nellis for that introduction i
am matt humes and it is my pleasure to
share a little bit about beam today
and some of the automation we've been
able to set up around our primary
workflow
beam is a relatively new biotech company
we came out of stealth mode about three
years ago and went in public
just about a year ago what we are is a
next generation gene editing
company at this point everyone is pretty
familiar with crispr
when talking about crispr the common
analogy that gets used is molecular
scissors
where they find a specific site cut the
double helix
which paves their way for cool things
like deletions or insertions of new dna
but sometimes you don't want to cause
that double strand to break and that's
where the base editors come in
if we continue the molecular scissors
analogy we are like a pencil and eraser
we can go in and specifically change
single base pairs within the genome at a
precise location
without inducing a double stranded break
so here is a very high level view of how
we do that
essentially we use a dead or modified
castline molecule
and the same guy rna that you would use
to target a particular site
and we tether a chemical modifier to
that complex
that modifier can come in and change a
specific base by the chemical
modification that you see on the right
side of the screen
deaminations that convert c to t or a to
g
this is very high level of course if
you're interested in learning more about
the specifics
please check out bmtx.com and you can
find links to the papers and data behind
this awesome technology
as you can imagine being a base editing
company there is a large amount of
next-gen sequencing
here is a very high level view of one of
our nvivo workflows
our base editor is paired with a
delivery mechanism in this case a lipid
nanoparticle
animals are then dosed and livers are
harvested for extraction
here's where it goes onto our automated
system which handles all of the
purifications
normalizations pcr and cleanup steps
pretty much everything up until it is
loaded onto the my seeks
so here's the journey of how we got
there when i was hired back in 2018
pretty much everything was manual you
can see from the cartoon
we couldn't afford one of those cool pcr
robots so we got an undergrad and a
cardboard box
those of you with automated systems can
probably remember these times
many of us were probably the undergrad
in a box at some point
which is pretty much how all automation
projects start
we purchased a liquid handler to address
the tedious and difficult sample
transfer steps
but quickly realized that this is just
one small piece of the entire process
we found ourselves coming back to the
system over and over again to perform
simple tasks
like sealing a plate centrifugation or
bringing a plate over to a reader
while a step in the right direction it
was not particularly groundbreaking
high throughput days pretty much
entailed just bringing the reader closer
to the liquid handler
so we decided to move to a fully
integrated system
to address these moments with the goal
of creating large blocks of walk-away
time
here are the broad metrics we consider
necessary for a device to fit into our
system and workflow
first it has to be high throughput which
means not only fast but formatted in a
way that it can keep up with our
purification process
which is done in 96 well plates and
streamlined enough to handle 10 to 15
plates per day with a high rate of
success
next the device itself needs to be
operated autonomously by scheduling
software
need to be able to load read and unload
the right plate at the right time and
send that data forward through the
process
also run parameterization was key for us
we never do the same thing twice the
conditions we read at
the number of samples how we blank can
all vary from run to run
even within a single run from plate to
plate
and we need to be able to pass that data
to the instrument programmatically
so that when we execute the read we know
it is doing exactly what we intend
lastly once our software has loaded the
right plate and the right parameters
were sent
we need to be able to trust the data
finding an instrument that we can rely
on to perform
the same way each run was vital to our
process
we looked at many of the existing
devices and chemistries out there
through the lens of our workflow and
instrumentation that we had on our
particular system
while all these methods work they each
had drawbacks
fluorescent assays require additional
sample prep they are dependent on the
performance of standard curves
and they utilize light sensitive
reagents it also gives no qualitative
data on the sample itself
off system devices create a huge gap in
our data continuity
in addition to being slow we do not want
usb sticks and file drops to be our main
source
of data transfers finally they're what i
call
semi-automated solutions which
internally have automation-friendly
specs
such as well-spacing but the tray itself
tends not to be sealable or movable
by most robotics for us the unchained
lunatic was the answer
it has a feature-rich api that allows us
to take the data we get from limbs or
sample scans on the system
and create experiment parameters on the
fly as well as accurately labeling data
that comes out of the device so there is
no gap in traceability
another pro for this is that there is no
sample prep there are no time consuming
serial dilutions or light sensitive
reagents
to program around all you need to do is
load a few microliters onto their plate
not only does this lower the cost per
sample it frees up robot time and
reduces those precious robot consumables
that are very hard to come by these days
the lunatic plate itself adheres to
automation standards making it easily
handleable
by robotic arms and liquid handlers
and lastly it is quite fast with a full
plate read around 10 minutes
partial plates significantly less than
that and it is able to be used in a gop
setting here is a high level view of a
typical 10 plate and 8 hour day
on the gantt chart the dark green blocks
represent dna purification steps
tan blocks are points where we need to
quant samples
and blue is our ngs library prep
consisting mostly of pcr and cleanup
steps
so without integration what does this
look like for our undergrad
as you can see within an hour our
technician has to come back to the
system four separate times to take
quants offline
throughout an 8 hour day this number
goes up to 20. what's really staggering
is this is just one assay
scale this up to multiple assays on
multiple systems across an entire week
and you can imagine the time that is
lost
by choosing a device that has met all of
our integration criteria we are able to
remove all of these touch points
instead of returning to the system 20
times throughout the day our team can
walk away for the entire length of this
eight hour window
freeing them up to spend more time
designing and executing experiments and
really pushing the science here at beam
and perhaps most importantly more time
is freed up for coffee
as i mentioned before this is a typical
eight hour day the lunatic allows us to
make this an end-to-end solution which
allows us to kick off
another set of these 10 to 15 plates
before our team goes home for the night
extending the workday even further
and now for my favorite part here's a
short clip showing all of this in action
from automated storage to sample loading
and reading
all made possible by the integration of
the unchained lunatic
[Music]
[Music]
all right so thank you everyone for
coming to hear beam's automation story
and thank you to our partners at
unchained for letting me talk with you
all today
thank you matt for that great
presentation i
fully agree more coffee breaks is always
better
now our next speaker felicia will talk
about her protein workflow with two of
our systems
lunatic and stunner now just before we
continue i would like to give some
background info on stoner
in essence stunners are using this
technology from lunatic
in combination with dynamic light
scattering
stunner is the first and only instrument
that has both full spectrum uv
and dynamic light scattering all in one
the combination of these two detection
methods provides a more in-depth
analysis of biological samples
standard provides information on the
concentration size
and polar dispersion
stunner does all of this with its unique
standard plate that only
needs 2 microliter per sample so low
volume high throughput dls to get the
size and pdi data you need
while quantifying protein concentration
all this is done in a 96 wall
plate-based format that powers high
throughput analysis
giving you all this data on 96 samples
in an hour
now i'm very glad to introduce our
second external speaker
felicia desarta joseph is a scientific
investigator
within the biofarm discovery department
at gsk
she gained her bachelor's in biological
sciences at university of leicester
she has seven years of experience
working at gsk
and built her expertise in biophysical
characterization
biopharmaceutical developability
crystallography
high triplet screening and automation
she has successfully developed an
embedded automation of several manual
processes
via miniaturization use of liquid
handling robots and scientific knowledge
but in her current role she is advancing
automation
and data capabilities to further support
streamlining of early biopharmaceutical
drug discovery
processes felicia the stage is yours
thank you nilis for the introduction and
for the opportunity to talk about
our uv vis protein quantification
workflow
using a liquid handler system which is
integrated with a lunatic
the agenda for my presentation today is
as follows i'm going to give a high
level overview of our workflow
the past and present state of why we
decided to proceed
with an integrated system how the liquid
handler and lunatic integrated system
performed
uv vis protein quantification and
finally
an example of our assay characterization
where we use the stutter for dls
for the overview of our workflow first
we receive a panel of purified proteins
which require screening
the liquid handler integrated system is
used to perform
all sample preparation a part of this
process
is to perform a uv-vis measurement via
the lunatic
to quantify the concentration of our
proteins
using the outputs from this measurement
the system will calculate the new
amount of sample and buffer required to
normalize the sample
and generate a new concentration new
concentrations are required throughout
our screen in order
to analyze our proteins by different
characterization assays
so where did we begin previously we
would need to perform all sample
preparation manually
using two different systems for uv vis
quantification
depending on the concentration we were
trying to achieve
one was used for concentration up to 20
mix to mill which was faster
and the other was up to 150 mg per ml
both systems were manual and it was
possible to measure one sample at a time
if there was a larger panel of protein
this was challenging and often required
repeats
due to failed readings or high
percentage cb
observed between replicates we wanted to
increase the speed at which we could
perform
our uv biz measurements that was a high
throughput
and low sample requirement this system
would ideally be
automation friendly such that the system
would be future proof
the lunatic was a product that looked
like it could fit this gap
in our process so we decided to
investigate it and compare it to our
current systems
during our comparison we identified that
the lunatic was comparable to both
of our systems up to their respective
concentration range
we decided to purchase the system and
investigate the possibility
to integrate on the liquid handler
system
what we managed to achieve was a system
which was fully automated
that could perform our uv-vis protein
concentration workflow
in the video you will see the liquid
handler
mixes the samples before aspirating and
dispensing
into the lunatic plates once this is
complete
the lunatic door will open and the
gripper arm
will transport the plates into the
lunatic
once the door is shut the measurement
will begin
and this will take some time depending
on the protocol
and the number of samples that we're
running
for today's purposes i've skipped the
wait time
once the measurement is complete the
door will open
and the gripper arm will retrieve the
plate it will then shut the door
and the workflow will continue using the
results from the lunatic
to generate new samples with a different
concentration
required for our assay characterization
for instance dls
for our assay characterization we
perform dynamic light scattering to
measure the size of our protein
in a solution previously we were
performing this manually
and the dlf assay required large amounts
of sample therefore we investigated
methods to miniaturize this assay
to reduce our overall sample requirement
we already knew the stutter plates were
avenable to automation
as we used the lunatic plates and our
protein concentration workflow
we compared the stunner to our legacy
dls system
which showed reproducible results where
the legacy system is shown in orange
and the stunner in the blue the shapes
are paired
are pairs of the same sample this showed
we could produce
the same data quality as our legacy data
using ninety percent less sample
and now we are routinely using the
scanners for our dls workflow
to summarize we have integrated the
lunatic with our liquid handler
this has allowed us to increase our
sample preparation efficiency
and speed reduce our personal resource
since we can walk away during sample
preparation and enhance the throughput
of our screen
for the standard we have reduced our
sample requirement by greater than 90
thank you for your attention i hope you
enjoyed this presentation
and i'll now hand back over to nellis
thank you all for attending our
presentation matt
felicia and myself will take any
questions now
you nellis matt and felicia for your
informative presentation
we will now begin the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
so nellis this question will be for you
can this method be used with rnas
yes that's the short answer our or our
system has
applications for dna rna
any kinds of protein so this also works
with all the integration steps so yes
thank you nellis and i've got another
question coming your way
what's the concentration range of
lunatic
so the lunatic has a concentration range
of 0.03 od
to 275 od that translates
in for dna double stranded it would
translate into 1.5 nanograms per
microliter
up until 13.7 milligrams per microliter
and for protein about 0.03
uh mixed per ml to 275 mix per ml
thank you nellis matt this question is
for you
how many samples can you handle in a day
10 plates of 96
as shown on the slides was this possible
with your former method
sure so that's a great question um the
previous method we were closer to
two to five plates and that was a very
busy hands-on day
with the integration our average tends
to be about 10 plates which allows us to
get through the entire ngs workflow
in the same day um on heavy days you've
actually been able to do
15 plus plates um without any
slowdown the bottleneck tends to be more
of the extraction process
uh the lunatic is quick enough to keep
up with as much as we throw at it
all right thank you matt felicia this is
for you
how much is your screening throughput
enhanced with lunatic and you can give
me just a ballpark number so i would say
our screening throughput has been
haunted by at least
five folds by basic integration
all right that's amazing thank you and
looks like we have one more question for
matt and felicia
how difficult was it to actually
integrate the lunatic
um sure i could start it's actually very
simple
the device itself was designed to not
only look good but actually be very
integration friendly uh
the flat face of the device allows for a
lot of robot access
so you have a lot of options um as to
where you put it another thing like i
mentioned in the
slides was the the plate itself is svs
format
um so allows us to use any kind of
robotic arm storage
or liquid handlers um for the most part
if you can handle a 3d four-wheel plate
um i've found that you can handle the
wound with six plates with weights just
fine
i would agree with matt as well that the
integration was pretty easy i think
overall it probably took us
about a week plus um to integrate the
system and then
start having our protocols and workflows
in place um
we had a similar system before that we
had integrated
so the predecessor drops and i think
that made it a lot easier as well
um and then in terms of communication
everything like
a network problem so i guess that makes
it nicer in terms of being
wireless
all right thank you again matt and
felicia
and uh thank you to all of our speakers
nellis dennis
matt humes and felicia desarto joseph
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor unchained
labs for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
we and we until next time excuse me
until next time
goodbye